the mining administration is planning to
roll out a new system aimed at speeding
up screenings for the flood of migrants
seeking asylum at the border under this
new rule u.s asylum officers can grant
humanitarian protection to migrants
that's something that only immigration
judges used to be able to do before this
rule rule also says officers cannot deny
protection migrants rejected during
screening must face an immigration judge
and it gives migrants the right to
appeal a judge's verdict former ice
director and former dhs deputy assistant
secretary jonathan fahey joins us now
jonathan do you think this new system is
going to help or hurt because um
texas attorney general ken paxton he
actually filed for preliminary
injunction in the u.s district court
saying this is actually going to
accelerate the illegal immigration
yeah i think that's a great question you
ask i think it's going to help and it's
going to help illegal aliens
get into the country and stay into the
country and it will encourage more so in
terms of helping it will help in that
respect but this is like
pretty much everything this
administration has done on illegal
immigration it is either designed to
increase illegal legal immigration or to
pretend like they're doing something
about the problem when in fact they're
not and this will this will actually do
both
jonathan how is this legal why does this
administration think that it can
literally remove jurisdiction from a
court and give it to a bureaucrat
yeah that's a really good question
because
you know what what are they doing here
they're basically delegating a judicial
role although these are not like article
3 judges but they're delegated
to
employees of uscis which is part of this
administration that's trained by this
administration so you you think what's
going on here is they are going to make
it easier for people to
be granted asylum
and
there and then once they're granted
asylum they're they're here
permanently with legal status but
granted the people that are not granted
asylum will also in effect be granted
asylum because they won't be removed
under any circumstances whatsoever and
that's one of the tricks with this
administration they talk about they'll
be put in deportation proceedings if
they're not granted to the asylum but
they won't actually be deported the the
line the list of uh people that have not
been deported it's over what i think
it's one and a half million people so
they'll just be put on that pile and and
at the rate of deporting 59 000 a year
you know we're looking at 25 years to
get get to the people that will be uh
order deported eventually jonathan what
are the the differences in
qualifications um for somebody who may
not know
with the asylum officers versus the
asylum judges and how could that be
dangerous or kind of muddy with
information that's given out
well i think some of the things that are
dangerous is if it's asylum officers
that are
you know that are trained that there's
no review of what they do so if they are
granting asylum to people that don't
deserve asylum
there's no way to review that there's no
court that there's no judge that's been
trained on this there's no it doesn't
look like there's even an adversarial
process in there it's just simply if one
of these
agents
of the uscis decides somebody grants it
they're going to they're going to be
granted asylum and it really should be a
very thorough process because asylum is
simply not
coming to this country saying you'd
prefer to live here than where you
currently live because you'll be
more prosperous here
these are people that are supposedly
fleeing persecution where they are and
this administration knows by and large
all these massive uh migration patterns
that have happened over the past year
and a half are not people fleeing
persecution they're people
fleeing to the united states because
they know they have joe biden as the
president and he's going to welcome them
with open arms and give them every right
privilege and benefit that american
citizens receive yeah to that point
asylum is a pretty tough standard to
reach 31 000 people were granted asylum
in fiscal year 2021.
under this new approach where judges are
essentially removed from the equation
jonathan how high will that number go
when you have look at the screen right
now a million people encountered at the
border in fiscal year 2022 so far
yeah you figure it's the design the
purpose of this is to
want to encourage more people to come
because they'll know it's going to be
easier but my guess is it will be lower
in that 90 percent number um you know so
if it does get lower than a 90
number the floodgates are even wider
open and also people will be granted
asylum very quickly and if they're not
growing asylum quickly they'll just be
put in the same old process and they're
no worse off you know in fact they're
they're you know they're they're going
to be staying in this country too so
yeah this will my guess is it'll be far
lower than what the normal standard is
and
the administration now will control what
that number is because they could train
people
to to let in as many people as they want
they can loosen the standards as much as
they want and we know that's what they
want to do this has been a political
move all along and they want as many
illegal aliens to come into the country
as possible and they're going to do
everything they can to do it and you
know maybe some of this is to make it
look like they're doing something to
protect some democrats in the midterms
but you know this is their their plan is
being executed as well as anything
they're doing in this administration
which is open borders and embassy and
unfortunately we're going to see how
that all plays out former ice director
jonathan fahey thanks for getting up
with us early on this memorial day we
appreciate it everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now